we want to find out how people find love
in 2015 because I could tell you it's
pretty freakin hard out there are you
single are you single you're not by any
chance on tinder right now are you do
you use online dating okay cubed
sometimes you meet people who are really
actually genuinely very nice but that
some people are just like I'm interested
in companionship but I'm also a sexual
creature so I'm open to that type of
intimacy
yeah the dating world can be rough maybe
that's why so many people are looking
down on their phones and they've got
tons of options sites like match and
OkCupid Ishq refer Muslims JDate for
Jews apps like tinder and coffee meets
bagel and even an app just to find
someone to cuddle with
you're between 25 and 34 years old
chances are you've tried online dating
so if you're single and ready to mingle
should you get online have you done
online dating yes I have I gave it a
shot I ended up meeting my boyfriend why
was it for four years so why are you
single how do you define single am I
getting laid no have you ever tried all
movie would you ever try it what sold
like I'm more of an in-person type of
guy you know because they lie or on a
dating sites like you might see a
picture and didn't see him in person it
is a little like somebody totally
different well online is really annoying
because I'm not I don't take good
pictures and it's all based on my
pictures essentially right well take
your sunglasses off let's see okay all
right
I'm really embarrassed the big reveal
they say eyes are the windows to the new
game for me and my friends just to ask
and find out and you know do it that way
instead of having like to hide behind a
facade of superficial questions as
compared to taking that chance and
there's someone shoots you down whatever
you get the chance something says yes
and oh my god now you got the new apps
like tinder and calm no I don't do that
why I won I want to pay for the service
if I do it you gotta they gotta get some
skin in the game I've used to do before
I'm actually deleted a little bit ago
just because it it was just no
connection I guess hard to find a
connection online how did you meet your
husband I met my husband eight years ago
on MySpace I still feel like my highest
quality matches and people that I meet
are people like within and outside of my
friend circle and that I meet in real
life so when you're on tinder what
exactly are you looking for a serious
relationship a soul mate or like a lot
of hooking up kind of stuff happens so
not too much like long-term success
short term yes long term not really
maybe that's why only 5% of Americans
who are married or in a committed
relationship say they met their partner
online as for everyone else I'm engaged
oh I fell in love the old-fashioned and
how is that I still believe in that yeah
I believe in